hello and welcome to this video
Karen 84 played played him a couple of
times already
now that was quite successful in some
games
see five
does that look like much no but
mitzvah'd seem I have seen games where
black was actually not was not that easy
for black to handle this position
so let's see I already have some idea
maybe I wind up on it's a little bit
exposed there
probably
ji-hye they can so play if he moves the
bishop
57mm only now
realized services and hectare malls
however night beef if I can play
a six
to work
it does not believe
I thought that this is basically winning
night c7c aid from the north
I think this is good
you
maybe this is this is straight away
losing I think that should win for what
you
hmm
mmm I only now realize that he can
actually just move this away it's a bit
embarrassing
and of course then I'm not winning of
absolutely not
I think it's better for white but not
winning of course stupid
the blacks problem is that b7 is very
weak I don't quite see how he defenses
long-term
so 97 now and aspirin
almost Vincent I can also just take c4
that's probably not a bad idea
[Music]
okay
let's see what his defensive approaches
maybe 95 somehow get this nearer to the
action
didn't even consider that okay I had a
set rock ring I can do this and take p7
you
was
rather
I'm testing defense let's see
mmm mmm
I think it was it was quite problematic
so c5 take take I've seen those things
also the dispositions and it's not so
easy because c5 is sticking out a little
bit okay c3 the engine wants to play
Knight c3 or a5 with an advantage if 5
makes maybe more sense than c3 oops I'm
sorry
c3 yeah he played very quickly and this
is a problem they played so quickly like
I don't know why is that a move that you
have to make in a split second oh this
is this is this is not a simple decision
what you do how to set this up and think
like how does white plague make maybe
you thought that is so harmless and you
can do whatever and I don't think you
can
so Bishop e3 and now you've got problems
you know this is giving and play
material 97 is just I cannot do that
the computer already wants to give up
the party so 96 is just a pretty serious
mistake okay see form 93-95 look a 2d
one
uh-huh
okay I don't think this can be bad and
now Knight e5 is better hmm
okay the ideas I'd seen this and then
this now I am having this discovered
attack and something like that is
definitely quite quite annoying still
Bishop e5 seems to hold by tactics
we're still have some pressure okay I
would not be five in black when a six
which I felt couldn't work but 97 is
stronger I thought I didn't see that
this is all that much
now the issues I thought this but 95 if
that is a strong move really very strong
I'm threatening this should be six night
take c7 yeah and if he takes it there's
a enormous double threat
plus this so as this just a twins
basically that means black has to do
this move and then I can be a coherent
and also when well witness too much
what is that this one for me
it's funny I said not why is that notice
in exchange is the night really not
coming home
it seems like that
it is what the engines evil is telling
me
Morrow and this wasn't super idea
amazing I thought I'm just clearly
better here like God was winning what I
I absolutely had not realized that this
book can yeah
I'm not on this
and then it's not winning but it's it's
annoying and probably better for Wired I
think that that is a very difficult
position to to defend
engine wants to play 95 yeah the debt
makes some sense they get this back but
still slow I think this is very
difficult this is all loose and you
don't really have come to play with
black
give it a bit of a time that deceive us
coming up yes going on
is it who find that some porn gets lost
it's just just my own gym
in the game lucky didn't really put up
much resistance here it is probably over
already
this was a very very quick Windham ok
guys thanks for watching